Hey! Welcome to new Project Kamp update!
This isJavier!
I'm from the video maker team.
Normally, I will be behind the camera,
but this time I'mgoing to be in front.
And, I'm going to present you this video, which is the challenges video.
So, everyten videos, we do a challenge one,
which are the ones that end with an 8.
And, we talk about our previous,current and coming challenges.
Also, we do a Q&A!
So, well, we're going to start now.
First, wegoing to Julie with our previous challenges.
- Okay, let me tell you something
about theprevious challenges we had.
At the moment, the summer peak is gone.
So, quite some peopleleft already.
For instance, the managing of the teams.
This becomes much easier!
Probably becausethe teams are getting way smaller,
so there are less things going on at the same time.
Butalso, the people in the teams,
they are here for quite a long time already.
So, they know howwe work
and this makes everything go way smoother.
Among the people that have left
were Wouter andDebbie with their baby.
This was quite a challenge we took on this year,
with having a baby on the Kamp.
But, overall, it went quite well!
A lot of small challenges that we have learned a lot from.
But, we alsoenjoyed many things!
Another thing: it's way less hot.
It might not look like it,
but I'mwearing long pants with socks and sandals.
And, actually, this relates to a lot of challenges we had.
For example: the working schedule.
This can be just staying as it was,
because we can workduring the whole day.
It's not extremely hot.
So, also, we can use the power tools whenever we needto.
This helps a lot, and it saves us some more energy
by the end of the day to do other stuff.
Another nice thing about the summer ending
is that there is way less fire risk.
Actually, we hadalready some rain, which is really helpful!
But, this doesn't mean that we can chill...
The fire in2017 was around autumn time.
So, we keep on taking precautions, care of the native trees
and makingthe land more fire resilient bit by bit.
We have all of these challenges quite under control!
But, we also have a long lasting challenge.
Actually, one that we haven't updated you for a while!
But, Dave is going to tell you more about that one.
- All right, so, the Community Center...
We have a fewbig challenges here.
You guys have also been asking for
what the status is on this project.
So, let me give you a good overview.
Originally, we always thought this would become a workspace.
But, later on, by being here, we realized what is
more important, which is a Community Center.
And, it'squite an important building, because it's going
to decide how many people we can host on theland.
When we saw the size of the building, we took some measurements.
And, we started figuring out on what we want in there.
We figured: ''Let's design it for 50 people.''
Which means we need to have a kitchenthat can host 50 people.
Maybe somewhere there?
We need to have toilets and showers...
Maybe somewhereover there?
A big living room, when it's raining outside or too hot
that we can be there also in a niceplace.
And, some offices for 10 people that could perhaps be upstairs.
This sort of gave ussome requirements of
what we want out of this building.
The next step was trying to figureout what would it actually look like.
So we started on playing a bit with the design.
Let me show youwhat we've done!
The first thing was making a 3D model,
out of the existing structure.
It'sfor us to understand better on how big it is.
But, we also wanted to invite the online community tohelp out.
So, we've put it online, so people could submit their designs,
with the requirements wehad.
We have a bunch of different ones.
Some people decided to use two different buildings...
Someone made one big building...
Someone made the double floor.
So, we have a bunch of designs coming in!
And, in the meanwhile, we also started working with the floor plan, like:
''How do we actually arrange thespace?''
''Where does it make sense to have a kitchen?''
''Where does the sun come up?''
''What's it like inthe winter and summer?''
We're really trying to position all the elements properly in this place.
Oneguy, who is helping out,
is Adrian from France, has been very helpful!
He was really excited, sowe continued making
more drawings with him as well.
We were going more detailed really!
But, we alsonoticed, like, we make all these drawings...
We kind of also need to make sure what is legally allowed!
Are there any rules and requirements from the outside world
towards this buildingin terms of fire regulations?
Or, maybe, some types of materials we can use?
So, before we go too deepinto the design,
we first needed to get into some paperwork.
All right, so, we're currently in ourlocal town!
In this building is the architect of the municipality,
that keeps an overview ofall the rules and regulations.
So, we went there a bunch of times with our paperwork,
to see what'sallowed and what isn't.
The main talks we had with the municipality was, on the one hand,
that we needto legalize the existing structure.
Because, the previous owner just built a building there,
butit was never in the paperwork...
So, we need to put it in.
And then, you need to look at the maps,
fireregulations and all this kind of stuff.
Then, we also wanted to know if we want
to build a newbuilding and on what is allowed.
Which depends a bit on you what are you going to do...
Are you going to sellstuff?
Are you going to produce things?
Is it for people from outside or just you internally?
Youneed to find out what's the
right category to build your building.
So, this means it's just a lot ofback and forth
with the municipality, to see what's allowed.
And, I think, also during this process,
werealized you need to get quite specific.
Because, every little decision has an effectsomewhere!
So, it's a good reality check to see
that it's easy to dream big with these buildings...
But then, this sort of really funnels it down
to what is allowed in this setting.
Just on what wecan do what type of building we're going to build.
So, we got a lot of good information!
A lotof rules and guidelines!
And now, we can go a bit deeper into the design process.
What'sthe building going to look like?
So, it's time to look into some of the designs.
The fun part!
Let me showyou some of the things that were made!
So, the original plan was that this is the building.
We use as much existing structures as possible.
We build a big roof on top and we fill up the holes
with other materials,like glass.
So, from the back, it would look like this.
You can see the bricks and then the holes
withsome other wooden frames inside.
So, from the top, the building would have one big roof.
And, if weopen it up, we keep the existing
inner walls to arrange the space.
To reuse as much possible.
So, from the top, you would have a kitchen area here.
More toilets and the sink here.
And, theeating area here.
So, here's a little clip, where you can see the inside.
As you can see, the space hasa lot of beams and reinforcements.
Just because the bricks are super fragile and brittle.
Alsobecause the building burned down!
So, to provide structural strength, we need to add that.
But, while also talking to the municipality, we realized it's going
to be quite hard to actually legalizethis existing structure.
Because, it's very unknown, based on the strength
and that it's not very properly built...
And also, if you want the building to be replicable for others...
It's kind of weird tostart off with this very specific structure.
So, we slowly gave up on the idea of having
to usethe existing structure.
We started thinking more like:
''Okay, what if we build it from scratch?''
So, wekeep the existing footprint of the building
and what it would look like from the outside.
But, wechange the inside, so this gives freedom
to rearrange of the building itself a bit.
Yeah, so, thisis one version based on that.
But, we also decided at some point to look
into keepingthe sides more open.
With an insulated space in the middle.
We moved it a bit more towards theleft,
so we can take advantage of the morning sun here.
So, we start started looking more into thoseareas as well, like:
''What is the ventilation in the building like?''
''How is the air flow?''
And because, forinstance here on the back side,
you have the wall into the ground.
So, it gives a lot of cooling.
But,also things like the sun:
''How do we take advantage of
the winter sun to heat up the building?''
''But, notfrom the summer?''
Because then, it heats up too much...
With all of that, we started makingour final layout,
on what we think would be good for the building.
So, what we have now is abig kitchen here and a dining room here.
A living room here, and a technical space
where we can have thesolar and the water system.
And here, like a cellar for the dry food for the kitchen.
Here a wetcellar, which is like this underground fridge.
Because it's underground here, it naturally coolsit.
And then, a stairs to the top floor.
On the top floor, you would have it open here.
So, youcan look down to the eating and the living area.
Here's an office, some showers and toilets...
So, we alsomade a few visuals!
It was mainly for the municipality
to get them excited about this building.
Thisis what it looks like from the front.
We had to lower the height a bit actually,
when showingthe plan throughout time to the municipality.
Because, we would exceed it's height...
Hereyou can see that it's built under a slope.
On the backside, you have the entrance as well.
So, you canexit on the first floor from the inside,
or here from the back.
From the front, you would also have anoutside area,
where you can eat more in the summer.
You can eat nicely outside.
And then, on the inside, wecould use some
Precious Plastic bricks to make the walls.
Here, you can see the stairs going to thetop.
So, this is the inside, and we're pretty happy with the design now!
It has everything we need!
So,here you have a big kitchen,
where we can cook for 50 people.
Here, they can all eat and have enough spacefor that.
In the back, a living room and then on the top,
you have the offices the showers andthe toilets.
So, this checks all our boxes and fits our needs, which is cool!
We're happywith it!
Now, we need to move to the next step.
All right, so, lastly, let's get into the
current challenges we have in this whole process.
The first one: ''What kind of material we going touse?''
Because, we decided to break it down,
due to it not being a 'very easy to legalize' structure,like this.
So, we're looking into what kind of natural materials can we use.
We have more anoption of using something traditional.
Like, straw bale mixed with clay.
You also have morenewer kind of materials, like hempcrete.
Or, using really an old school way of building,
which ismore traditional as well.
It's with big granite rocks which is a
very local materialyou'll find a lot around here.
But, we kind of need to decide which material to use...
It has abig impact in terms of budgeting and finding the material.
Also, finding the right people that can workwith it.
The main challenge is just this:
''How can we make sure it's going to last
in the humidperiods in the winter?''
''And, also how can it maintain a good temperature
in the super hot summers?''
So, we're trying to figure out and decide
on what is the best material to use.
The second challenge isabout the utilities.
So, to really calculate how much do we need.
If we know we're going to be with50 people,
what's the size of the solar system we need for instance?
To make sure we powereverything,
so the batteries and the wattage we need to generate.
Also, the water system.
What'sthe capacity we need?
How big of a storage tank we need for the buffer?
The sewage system...
Also, theutilities in the kitchen itself.
Like, what kind of equipment do we need?
How much and which kind ofdevices?
Yeah, this is something we really need to nail down...
Because, it would also affect the building a bit
and the arrangement inside.
So, it's an important question we need to answer!
Thethird challenge is finances.
And, just so you know, all these challenges are in a research module.
So, you can follow the whole process!
And, you can also give comments and suggestions,
if you have, any which is very helpful.
It's better to put them there, than in the YouTube comments, becauseit's a bit messy in YouTube...
Anyway, the finances!
So, we roughly measured that the building wouldbe
between €200.000 and €300.000 to completely build.
To have all the utilities inside!
which is a bigupgrade for the project
because we can host much more people.
But, it's also quite a big chunk ofmoney that we don't have...
And, we're in this weird position a bit,
because officially if you filefor your paperwork...
You need to build the building within 2 years after that.
But, we don't know ifwe have the money,
so we don't know if you can commit to that.
Or, you do it the other way around, where you say you first
get the money and then you have the final drawing.
So, we're not surewhat's the best approach here to take.
In terms of the money, we were thinking of doinga crowd fund.
We're not really sure yet how or how to set this up...
But, in general, we really like youguys for all of the support!
We also know it's a lot of money to fund from people.
So, we're not sure ifwe're going to make it.
I think it's also one of the things we always have in mind.
That, in one hand,the building would help
to be with more people on the land.
Which then can do more useful research...
But, also,we want the building to be replicable,
so others around the world that want to start a community...
They can use the drawing as a base.
So, it should be somewhat useful, because drawings likethis...
You don't really find them.
You maybe find a drawing for a house or like a small household,
but nota Community Center for multiple people.
So, in a way, we also feel the drawing is useful for the world.
But, anyway, whilst thinking about this, we also realized:
''How do you get this amount ofmoney for a project,
that is somewhat for the world, but it might be exclusive for here?''
And, I guesswe realized we don't really have our vision very clear...
What does this project really want to do?
What's the plan in the long term?
So, then you also know if it's worth to support it.
But, this isanother challenge that Rita
is going to talk a bit more about!
- Yes, the vision.
So, a few years ago, we arrivedto the land with a notion of
wanting to live a more sustainable way.
But, we didn't really have aplan for that...
And, it was really good, because it gave us one to two years
to just observe and to get toknow the land.
But now, as the project complexifies and grows...
We feel the need to create reallya vision
that aligns the team a bit more.
Just so that it's easier to communicate with you guys,
our audience,or to anyone that likes the project.
The complexity in that is that the project is quite broad
and itplays with words like 'sustainability'.
There is a different interpretation for each person thathears it.
We really need to go into that deeper,
and to understand that deeper.
Because,it will also help us to do the long-term documentation.
So far, we have been doing these weekly recaps.
It's super cool, entertaining and it help us to document a bit.
But, it doesn't go very deep inknowledge...
What we aim on is to really share a bundle
of information that can be replicatable.
The challenge in there is that we live in
a very specific context and different setting.
So, it hasvery specific needs and very specific policies.
And, we want to find out what kind of information can beuseful.
For example, to live in the jungle on the outskirts of a city.
This is basically justgoing through a big pile of information,
sorting what's useful and what's not useful.
And, on the otherhand, we also have a day-to-day stuff
that takes over all of our capacity...
But, as the system growsstronger and more self-sufficient...
We get a bit more space for that and to look into that.
Thatgives us a bit more space to also
look into social documentation.
Documentation of social aspects.
How do you document community building?
How do you document feedback loops and the creating oftrust?
It's quite challenging, because basically you cannot really make a drawing
or a blueprint ofdocumenting conflict management.
So, we are in this whole process of figuring out
on how to make thislong-term social documentation.
And, basically at the foundation of it,
how to livea resilient life and to live in a sustainable way.
- In our building project, we try to reuseas much materials as we can.
And, we'll use as much recycled materials as possible.
But, as we move forward, manyquestions pop up.
These are questions that haven't got an easy answer.
For example, this isolation isrecycled textile.
But, this needs always a new layer of plastic to make it watertight.
This, for example, is cork, which is like a new material and it's natural.
And, it doesn't need the use ofthis new plastic foil on the building.
Another question is to bring non-natural
materials toa natural environment.
Which, when working with them, like cutting or moving around...
It alwaysreleases some particles of plastic
or different non-natural materials.
So, this also rises thequestion like:
''Is it nice to bring this kind of materials
to this kind of environment?''
So, thisis our pig trailer, and these colors rise the question
also of the recycled and reused look.
Somepeople like it more, and some people like it less.
I think it's quite funny anyway!
But, this always comesback to that you need to reuse materials.
You try to find the materials that accomplish the technicalmission.
But, maybe then you cannot have control on how it looks like...
Even more, in this naturalenvironment,
introducing these looks can be a bit rough.
- Okay! Those were our current challengesso far!
Now, we're going for the Q&A.
This time, it's going to be a bit different.
Because, it's goingto be me walking around
Project Kamp with this spoon microphone.
Asking questions to the people!
And,then also, Adrian and Julie had to leave,
but they are going to answer remotely.
So, alsothat's something we want to try and integrate.
Yeah! Let's see how it goes!
Have you consideredselling the mechanical parts of the yellow van,
now that it's no longer a mobile vehicle?
- I didn'tconsider it...
They're in there and we don't use them!
So, if you want to get them, you can come and takethem out.
- Okay, a question for Adrian!
Why have you put the pig trailer so far away from the Kamp?
- So,for now, we moved it mainly to have less noise in Basekamp.
And, also, a nicer place to record and tomake the projects.
In the future, we probably want to move away a bit more
from the workspace to theliving area.
There's many reasons for it!
But, so far, I cannot say way more,
because we still don'thave a proper plan for it...
- Do you crave any favorite fruits from your homeland,
and how do you deal with it?
Yeah,so, at this time of the year, I really miss 'pepernoten',
which are these tiny little Dutch biscuits!
I deal with it by getting the chefs to make it for us in the oven.
- My mom's food and I can't deal withit.
It's too much.
- The only food I would crave would be French fries
or Belgian fries, as we callthem.
If I want them, I can just make them,
because I work in the kitchen.
- Asado!
It's the Argentinian word for barbecue.
And, actually, we did one a couple of weeks ago outside the Kamp.
- Pa amb tomàquet, which is bread withtomato and a good olive oil!
Croissants and cabbage, and I never eat them.
Then when I do, it will be amazing.
- I do like a lot of Dutch cheese and chocolate sprinkles!
So, every now and then, I have friends
or my family passing by to drop me some.
- Roughly translated, it's called Tree Cake,
because it has likelayers like a tree.
I don't deal with it, because I don't have it, so...
I'm sad I guess.
- Imiss the salted butter, but there is olive oil, so it's okay!
Have you guys thought about making bermsand swales
to hold more water in the ground?
- Yeah! We thought about that!
But, it wasn't really thetime for it in the summer yet...
We're actually starting it soon.
So, in the recent updates,
you would see usmaking quite a few of them.
- Will you be planting more trees soon?
Yes.
- Hey Tincho!
A quick question:
When do you expect the tractor for Project Kamp?
- We need two more ads!
We're still thinkingabout if it's going
to be a digger or a tractor.
If you want more info, you can go to the research module.
Link's in thedescription!
- Oh, and also, there are many flies here, no?
A lot!
It's very annoying!
- I'm going!
What about thebiogas, Timo?
- Well, the biogas digestor has moved to its new place here.
But, we're still waiting forthe right gas to come out of it...
You'll hear about it in a future update.
- This one is for Julie!
What is the average number of people
involved in the Kamp on a daily basis on site?
- Normally, around 25.
Sometimes, when neighbors come, it's 27.
When people are on holidays: 24...
Now that we are not there, it's 22.
So, it's alwaysdifferent!
- Is there something that newcomers to the Kamp
were surprised about or expecting differently?
I think at least myself and I think other people too...
Everything is way steeper like super steep!
And, in Basekamp, everything is closer together.
In the video, it looks like more spread out
but then it'scloser together.
But, mainly, everything's steep.
- But, you are not a newcomer.
No, I came long time ago, butstill it's still steep for me...
- The size of this place!
I thought it was smaller, but when youcome here,
you can see that it's quite big.
Every place is much closer than it looks like in thevideos.
And, also at night, it used to be very cold!
- For me, I would say that my expectations
really match up with how it really is to live here.
Cleaning the poop buckets is not as bad asit seems.
- With the videos, there is always lot of things going on.
At the Kamp, it's more chill and we can takea nap.
It's better!
- How do you deal with the laundry of so many people?
It's actually not thatbad!
We have a beautiful washing machine.
It's a Dutch washing machine over here.
And sometimes, if it's been like really cloudy or a cloudy week...
We have a bunch of people piling up
as soon as thesun comes out!
But, in the whole, it works pretty well.
We share our loads when possible
and hang themin the sun to dry.
- What's your take on the mobility?
Driving petrol cars has a huge impact
on emissionsand plastic particles.
I almost never see bikes in your videos.
Probably because the Kampis too far away from everything...
Well, we do use petrol cars, as you've seen.
We renovated the pickup.
And, we have the blue car, which is the caddy.
We are quite far away from many places, but...
I live in a town nearby, and I take my bike
almost every morning and cycle here, so...
And,there are some other bikes inside there from the people.
We take them every now and then, but thething is...
Normally, we don't move much away from the Kamp.
Maybe in the weekends?
It'smore like one car driving with many people around.
So, although we use cars, I think we are doingquite well, I would say.
So, regarding solar electric production:
What are your plans to preparefor a more steady occupation of the land?
Do you change the orientation of your panels between seasons?
Haveyou listed possible ways to
use solar electricity surplus in summer?
To produce energy intensivestuff
that you will use later in the winter?
- We are not thinking very much ahead yet.
We cannotcollect the electricity surplus
that we have in summer for the winter.
The only surplus that we collect sofar is when it's very sunny.
We connect the electric water boiler,
and we keep hot waterfor later.
So far, we never changed inclination, but we could!
So, we are ready to put it up.
- What you learnedabout communal living?
There's always a shoulder to cry on.
A little bit about communication,but not so much this far.
- What have you learned about communal living?
It's great and there's alwaysfood!
- Make sure to find your own time.
What I've learned is that you really need to rely on otherpeople.
- That if somebody annoys you, it's you who's the problem.
I have learned the importance of humantouch.
- It's a lot of fun!
That is hard work, but, bit by bit,
we are seeing the positive parts of communal living!
- I don't really know, but it's nice to live all these days
with lot of different people.
So, you didn'tget tired yet?
Hey!
One question: what have you learn about communal living?
- You need to find your own space.
Like now?
- Just like now.
Sorry!
Have you guys considered a biogas plan
to help with the poop situation?
- At the moment, our poop situation is
kind of covered with composting.
And, will you be adding animals to the Kamp?
- I don't know!
People talk about goats?
I don't know...
Does it make sense to get goats?
- Ilike goats!
What do you guys think? Should we get goats?
- Yeah, should we?
What is the bigbiggest time consuming thing in a week?
- We move a lot of stuff around since
we're working at the pig trailer and in the workspace.
They're not in the same working spot.
- Probablymaking everything from scratch,
because we don't have all of the sorts of milk.
Westopped buying tofu and saitan.
So, we have to make that ourselves also.
Which is quite timeconsuming, yeah...
For us, in General Help, I think is moving the mimosas.
Cutting them is okay, but likedragging them
making a pile and then dealing with the pile...
That takes weeks and weeks.
- Chester,what is the most time consuming thing in Project Kamp?
So, I think for the bread team the most
time consuming thing is getting this thing hot enough!
It takes about 2 and a half hours!
It'sactually still warm from yesterday's baking, but yeah...
That takes a lot of time.
- 3D-modelingfor sure.
What about updating and posting videos on winter season?
- Well, during the the winter,we just want to chill.
It's been an intense season, so...
But, anyway, we will probably post some updates in Patreon.
- Could you give us some stats on how the electric
and water systemsare performing with more people in Kamp?
So, about our stats, we don't have much water stats collected.
We recently start a sensor there.
But, we still don't have the proper stats to share.
So,we don't know, and we didn't analyze it...
About the solar stats, here you can see
the September 2022 stats withbetween 10 and 15 people.
The battery was always high!
It's the sunniest time of the year, so it was good.
Here you have stats from 2023,
with around 25 people in the Kamp.
The same amount of panels
and the same amount ofbatteries.
But, the battery, as you can see, is way lower.
So, for September, we aim for changing this situation a bit.
But, I will tell you about it soon, not now.
- One last question! Ale!
Howis the weather in this season compared to the last?
Do you still have enough water in thelagoon
to cool off now and then?
Well, there's two questions...
- About the water, you can see that westill have a good level.
There was a time in mid August that was like halfway like this.
But, it was still manageable!
About the weather, I really don't know.
I was not here last season.
Do you maybe know?
- I was here last season, and I can say that this summer
has been less hotthan previous summer.
That was extremely hot, at least in the area we are at now.
Okay, thank youAle! See you!
That was it for this challenges video!
The next update is going to be us making the pig trailer waterproof.
Or, at least, we're going to try.
And also, we're finishing of the cleaning of the road.
So, if you already want to watch it now,
you cansupport us on Patreon.
You can also get the videos in 4K and without ads!
And, if not, you canjust continue watching on YouTube.
Subscribe, leave a comment and help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching and see you in the next update!